so are are you like all in on like nfts
I I know I mean I'm all in on nfts the
nft technology is remarkable it's insane
why don't people see it Gary because a
lot of people don't see it because the
first year of people discovering it
they're scammiest friend made eighty
three thousand dollars selling a penguin
with a penis in its eye
of course people don't normal people
don't get it they're right it's the same
reason people didn't get the internet in
99 you had normal people saying how the
hell is pets.com worth 85 billion
dollars they haven't sold any stuff yet
I'm not even sure chewy.com has that
valuation you know so like you know
they're because they're right the greed
took over the short-term flipping took
over and that shadowed the incredible
you know black and white of the
incredible technology infrastructure of
a global scaled Ledger that can affirm
ownership that can unlock
everything Gary what's up man welcome
back to bankless
it's so good to be with you guys thank
you so much thanks for everybody who's
watching it's a rainy day here in New
York City indeed it is but um but uh I'm
grinding along it's been a big day well
you know what grinding I think is a good
theme right because uh we're at least in
The Wider crypto World we're in kind of
this this bear Market you know
um and so that's what people tell me
anyway I'm not feeling particularly
bearish but uh some people are prices
are down in a lot of areas it's been
about a year and a half I think you came
on in May of some time 2021 uh yeah in
launching V friends during kind of this
this secular bull market that we had in
nfts and crypto like in general
um
tell us what you've been up to since
that time like catch us up and and give
people a feel if you will Gary for like
what is the V friends project itself
like what is the purpose of it and what
have you been working on since we last
spoke
I mean since we last spoke a ton because
that was just the launch of series one
since then
that August September I created
something called book games where if you
bought 12 copies of my latest book you
would get nfts that I did on a mutable
which then became like functional for
something I did in January where there
was an exchange and then that triggered
advantages to get series two mints and
special series twos that nobody else
could get series two came out
in May of this year
um uh or in April and then the big play
the original premise of the friends was
to establish intellectual property Smurf
Scooby-Doo
um all that stuff and um and Disney
Pokemon like how substantial of a Sesame
Street like IP can I create because it's
something I've always wanted to do if
you look at you know you look at
wrestling and toys and garage sales this
has been Obsession of mine I thought I
was going to buy a nostalgic IP this was
something I talked a lot about in my
career once I saw the nft uh realities
of 2021 it was funny when I saw crypto
kitties in 17 I was like huh but I just
didn't I didn't really get there
2020 NBA Top Shot and then that brought
me quickly to crypto punks and I was
like oh and then obviously everything
that happened that winter into 2021
um so the mission has always been
building intellectual property things
like the Uno collaboration like I've got
to build these characters I now at a
higher level the characters are meant to
do what Gary vaynerchuk likes doing as
Gary B which is
spread positivity and kindness and
compassion and patience but also
tenacity and work ethic and you know I
think we've become so blue and red
and I'm so deeply passionate about
purple the world has become or it's
really about and and I have a
substantial mission for beef friends to
be a positive impact on the universe the
way Marvel and Sesame Street and other
intellectual properties have
um done so
and so that's been the focus on top of
that
to make the initial cost valuable to
people I did a three-year super
conference right called vcon and so
since we last talked I think I had one
of the most substantial events in the
space which was in Minnesota at U.S Bank
Stadium we had seven eight thousand
people there it was an incredible four
day weekend we had an incredible amount
of speakers and just enormous amounts of
love and positivity and practicality and
you know to me I'm very proud of the
initial costs of the friends being
valuable to the three events that people
are going to we'll be announcing vcon
2023 probably this month which is way
ahead of what we did last year we've
learned a lot
um Uno collaborations
merchandise collaborations a Reebok
sneaker collaboration that is
coming uh trading cards that if you go
to eBay right now have completely
dominated which has been huge for me so
you know like little subtle things I
keep trying to expand the IP like I grew
up loving Flintstones Vitamins I did a
collab with Mary Ruth wow that's awesome
you know and so you know I've been doing
a lot uh what I haven't been doing
is look I said my piece
I put out an obnoxious amount of content
in the height of the height of the
height and I received smile in there
David so you know what I'm about to go I
have unlimited receipts
of saying 99 of the projects that were
booming in the boom were going to zero
so why I believe that because I saw the
behaviors I didn't feel like I felt it
was internet stocks I mean I said it
constantly you guys both know this
so what I've been doing is the thing I
said I was going to do which is operate
and work and build a forty five fifty
person team
I've got another 30 hires I have
meetings every day
I raise capital for me Andresen Horowitz
because I want to be around I don't know
how look we're in a bear Market I don't
know who's excited forget about crypto
is anybody paying attention to
the severity of the war in Europe the
macro politics there the inflation
the underlining reports from FedEx
housing's about to crash I really
believe that a lot of companies consumer
confidence is down
and so I don't know like I don't expect
the great winter
you know and so like it's not like this
my my stock portfolio doesn't look good
either compared to last summer and my
trading cards don't look great and
I don't know what you know people expect
like the economies don't go on forever
right and so
you know what have I been doing
everything I said I was gonna do right
which is like really work really really
hard and I'm very proud of the work I'm
doing and we've got a lot of work to do
and to get to the audacity of saying
things like Marvel or Scooby-Doo or
Hannah Barbera or Transformers that's
going to take the rest of my career and
that's what I plan on doing this is
forever for me
and um I've got to create demand and
interest and character development like
I've got
an ecosystem and then I have to do
incredible
um interesting technology like one thing
I've not alluded to at all I know my
Discord is about to blow up let me go
into my Discord to see if any because I
know a lot of them are watching
um you know I've been doing a lot of
tech Innovation we have a hefty Tech
Team who's been building something I'm
very excited about
um that will hit the day of life this
year and it's pretty Advanced Tech you
know you got a lot of web too a lot of
web3 we're playing a lot of web 2.5 do
you need everything to be anonymous
that's how it felt 18 months ago now is
username and sign in worth it to make
the utilities of the things like it's
super fun and and then to your point
what else have I been doing I've been
staying mentally strong while the you
know Market in the macro has been
incredibly affected and I'm incredibly
compassionate
that there's anxiety and concern and
angst and winter Vibes
um I you know I hope and pray that
everybody heard rule number one which
was consistent which is do not spend
money you can't afford to lose in these
high things you know a lot of people did
and you know I continue to try to
provide value like I love that you can
continue to add utility right I did this
incredible Meetup at my dad's store at
The Wine Library for people that have
The Wine Cellar it was a great time
we've done some great stuff with my my
pickleball team meetups
um
and then unofficial things I'm in
Germany giving a keynote let's go meet
up with 200 be friends holders so just
really focused you know just incredibly
focused and focus like an athlete like
my New York Jets who beat the Pittsburgh
Steelers this weekend they were down by
10 points very late in the game
the fans in Pittsburgh were cheering
with seven minutes ago laughing at my
Jets the Jet fans were concerned booing
their own players
I have to be an athlete on the field I
can't even my most Ardent Believers pre
be friends
have said things in Discord and Twitter
that hurt my feelings but I understand
why they have Financial losses on paper
if they haven't been sold yet and it
doesn't feel good when something's worth
something and then it's not but I have
to stay focused on the field and tune
out any positive or negative comments
just like when I was getting the
accolades last winter I didn't hear it I
needed to focus on the mission and
that's that's what I'm focused on like a
falcon Focus Falcon's a big V front
um I'm focused like a falcon and I'm
gonna let history be the judge not me
[ __ ] me and definitely not
Anonymous accounts on Twitter who've got
opinions who've never operated a paper
bag let alone a big company sure
Gary there's a lot of just nft projects
out there and some some like you said
have like you know trended to zero
others are keeping their head above
water others are doing fine what what
are you doing that you think is working
like what what's the secret sauce to
make an nft Project work these days and
what things might an NFP project need to
jettison if it's not working that's like
what what things are we keeping what
things are we doubling down on what
things are we genusing I don't I don't
judge something working based on floor
price sure yes but like and like
Community energy community community
like engagement you can't you can't
value that either too many people are
financially incentivized and everyone's
getting smoked
and then like like like it okay whatever
whatever criteria of success you want
well that's I'm setting it up right like
to your point David I think people are
very confused about businesses like
Facebook was a disaster this many months
in like I'm pumped for invisible people
I'm pumped for you know creatures I'm
pumped for world people are working
the problem is they're all publicly
traded company DNA now right like people
care about it day to day I just want to
tell everybody because I was close to
these companies they're the [ __ ]
receipts right there this is this is
like back to receipts I'm in the [ __ ]
Robert salad they're like this is an
email from Uber thanking my brother for
being the first Rider of uber in New
York wow that's very cool
he's a [ __ ] receipts brother like and
I can tell you right now 18 24 months in
none of these companies looked great
I'm not [ __ ] willing to judge [ __ ]
board ape yet I'm not willing to judge
any of these projects yet and so I think
like you know I don't know like what
what to answer your question the people
I'm building an organization I'm focused
on the people the process you know like
there's there's missteps along the way
the gift goat has not gone as well as I
want to I've jumped in and tried to work
it but it takes months for these things
to you know you know execute on so I
focus on that I'm excited about you know
like the people I'm bringing in the
talent you know I just uh my partner in
empathy wines John Troutman just
finished his earn out a constellation is
coming to consult with fee friends
that's a note and you know when you're a
head coach and you're bringing back one
of your assistants you know like I don't
know I'm [ __ ] I'm focused out here so
anyway to answer your question the
things that are working what you keep is
the people on your team that can do [ __ ]
what's not working people that can't do
[ __ ] and you've given them a chance but
they haven't you gotta really go and so
I'm an operator like and I'm not willing
to put my head up from the sea and see
what the stock ticker says it has
nothing to do with anything for me
meaning I'd love for everything to be
Rosy but I'm not in control of that
I didn't call Pooh and then say go
attack Ukraine
that wasn't me
I've got to focus on [ __ ] defense and
what I'm doing is laying the foundation
for a lot of people to care about these
characters
which will build a real company which
will allow me to do incredible things
for the people that hold the nfts what's
interesting to me is right so as you
said like over 99 of these nft projects
are gonna die this bear cycle right like
we have to be real about that but one
percent might survive it might be a
fraction of one percent What's it gonna
take what what does it take to survive
during the bear market and Gary what's
what's it going to take to restore
confidence and entities like when are
nfts actually going to come back is
there some feature that we have to
unlock is there a focus area is it like
all about utility now like what's the
new meta and how do we get out of this
bear Market
a couple things I want to apologize to
Dewey Perrin who just said in the
comments I think this guy's Inseparable
insufferable so I obviously I want to
apologize for that because I don't want
to make you really upset
um you know I think people have to
provide value to your point when Marvel
comic books came out in the 40s right
30s what have you after years of
cartoons and toys and other Comics
people then cared and all of a sudden
you cared to own you know a Spider-Man
or a Superman in DC or Batman and and so
if you're talking about collectible
value like I just want to own this like
a like a Andy Warhol or a Spider-Man
number one or a Jordan sneaker that
takes decades
it you know which is why I made those
videos about 99 to zero like it wasn't
going to work like it went too high more
like beanie babies or stocks like
pets.com in in the me in the short term
to your to your point it's going to be
utility what that utility is is access
uh other items physical items you know
community events
the thing that I started to be friends
with like be friends were sold
with an underlining three-year super
conference that justified the initial
cost then [ __ ] got crazy and depending
on when you got in it changed the
variable but the original layout was
thoughtful to this moment because you
need to provide value right and so I
think you know every project needs to
think about can this is the beauty of
the blockchain can I add more value for
the person that's holding it value comes
in a million different things uh I just
did something with the gift goats I
mentioned that I'm not happy with you
know the gifts that I've been saying I
need to do a better job I added nfts as
part of it early on and I think that
might have [ __ ] with my psychology but
they want the gift and then I added a
new thing this October
the gift goats and I are going to be in
Atlanta for two hours in an epic
basketball court
right with Shaquille O'Neal
that's just a very small group probably
only 100 to 200 of the 555 gift codes
can make it because they're all over the
world you know an intimate two hours of
business q a some fun and games some
photos some hanging out you know like
how did you get how did you get Shaq on
board
I I use my business development skills
you know I also have a lot of
relationships this is why I'm confident
this is why I keep believing in myself
like
brother I'm not going to stop until it's
good like I don't understand how anybody
doesn't understand that I'd rather
[ __ ] die than let cynics be able to
write the history of new friends not
being a good project I could do this
forever
I'm gonna do this forever
so are you like all in on like nfts I I
know I mean I'm all in on nfts the nft
technology is remarkable
it's insane why don't people see it Gary
because a lot of people don't see it
because the first year of people
discovering it their scammiest friend
made eighty three thousand dollars
selling a penguin with a penis in its
eye
think about that of course people don't
normal people don't get it they're right
it's the same reason people didn't get
the internet in 99.
your normal people saying how the hell
is pets.com worth 85 billion dollars
they haven't sold any stuff yet
I'm not even sure chewy.com has that
valuation you know so like you know
they're because they're right
the greed took over the short-term
flipping took over and that shadowed the
incredible you know black and white of
the incredible technology infrastructure
of a global scaled Ledger that can
affirm ownership that can unlock
everything
you know what's what's interesting about
this market and it's maybe different
than other businesses you've run but
like you tell me it's like people aren't
used to the volatility of crypto like it
messes with their minds it messes with
them psychologically right right we've
seen the internet before but like it's
hatching prices and tickers to these
things is weird is like throws people
around I'm empathetic man money [ __ ] up
things yeah I mean the highs are so high
and the lows are so low and the just the
sense of like they have to play with
money they can afford to lose it's a
volatile asset right now
Ever Changing
of course
when this becomes normalized you know of
course but I also think it changes
in certain projects like
it has to be able to do something it
can't be a speculative thing this is why
I've always liked nfts I understood that
the entrepreneurs could create the thing
it does
right like whereas with with you know
and that and currencies can too but I
just think too many people are relying
on comic book and art and toy flipping
and baseball cards not enough on
operational business like you need to
think like Amex black card and Chase
rewards and
Live Nation and
tops and Mattel like you have to think
bigger business are you seeing these big
businesses like continuing to build
during the bear market so David and I
just did an episode last week and like
we noticed like Disney is hiring lawyers
IP Specialists to specialize in their
blockchain IP technology I mean
Sotheby's just rolled out an entire
platform for nft art and these things
during the the Bull Run uh I mean they
were shattered from the rooftops
everyone was talking about it now during
kind of the the bear run some of the
developments of these like companies are
completely unnoticed like no one even
pays attention no one cares what are you
seeing from your side are big companies
entering the game
it's like you know
my energy is very a matter of fact the
men because like it's almost as if
nobody heard all the logical
conversation of last year for me or
anybody else right like yes this is one
of the biggest technology shifts of the
human race
but everything was so caught up in the
short-term flip game that just clouded
yes to your point if you have Google
alerts on nft right now and you read
what's happening day to day you would be
bullish
you're not bullish because you bought
a nft for eight thousand dollars that's
now trading at six hundred dollars and
you're mad
and you're supposed to be mad I get it
but I hope that you're also mad at
yourself that you knew you were taking a
risk like don't be mad at anybody but
yourself kind of thing accountability is
important like I have a ton of things
that have gone poorly and I'm like ugh I
got caught up I got excited but I also
was buying for different reasons I was
trying to learn this is why I was
petrified the only thing I tweeted more
than 99 of going to zero was don't buy
what I'm buying because I know I was
buying things because I wanted to learn
how people were going to do things than
if it was in my wallet see if they like
I was in discovery mode
um supporting people that I just met on
Twitter because I want to because I want
to that's not a good investment thesis
you know I like this person I want to
support their art like you know so there
are worse investment thesis out there
than that though yeah there is and I
think thank you and I I feel good about
it but like you know I'm in a curious
spot I have a lot of eyes on me and so
I'm empathetic to it but yeah brother
like Disney's really not fooling around
Mattel is not fooling around like like
you know Pokemon's not like this is real
stuff Gary I'll tell you one thing it's
gonna happen because you guys announced
it today this is a big V friends
announcement and this is on what we were
just talking about big companies
entering the game here you've got a
collaboration of collectible characters
with Macy's and Toys R Us is that what's
happening this is a big deal for me all
all 400 plus Macy's around the country
that have Toys R Us store within stores
we'll be getting the friends literally
you know right next to GI Joe and My
Little Pony and Transformers and Pokemon
be friends end caps everywhere plush and
collectible and then and then Blind Bags
little ones uh it's a huge deal it's
also huge I haven't talked about I'm
giving you kind of the exclusive the
flow code is gonna be a big deal right
now it's a preview page but long form
content around the character development
think He-Man so He-Man came out as toys
earlier than the cartoon was ready so
they put little comic books in the toy
so that you could get into He-Man
because there was no way to get into
He-Man 99 of people that are going to
see this in Macy's Toys R Us stores
around the country have no idea what be
friends are
so kids are going to kind of like
hopefully fall in love with the imagery
this wizard is super cool
right and so like you know but the
storytelling like I'm really on this
Mission guys so anyway huge Distribution
on macy's.com right now on pre-sale
International it's coming in two weeks
on v-friendshop we'll be doing the
Fulfillment for international but this
is how you do it this is how you get
people to start getting involved and
like the more people fall in love with
the be the bigger person character
right the more things start to happen
where I can do something with those 260
holders of series 1 and Series two big
the bigger person like this is super
exciting I think people are missing what
real operators are going to be able to
do and I think real operators have to
build Affinity in the characters toys
books
cartoons movies but then also build
technology and utility for the original
nft holders and I'm on that Journey so
this is like this is like an IP play
almost right it's kind of like Marvel
it's kind of like Star Wars so what's
interesting about the way you're doing
it right is like you start with the
digital the nft yes and you're working
towards the physical whereas like
traditional like a Disney or you know
some other big IP player they're
starting with the character and then
moving to another direction right well
well they started with whatever they
started with Pokemon started with a card
game right and then a video game and
then a cartoon like Harry Potter started
as a book yes like magic The Gather like
like you know like so no you start with
what you start with right I've got a
huge thing coming out with Reebok right
so Reebok
huge collaboration coming out so I've
got you know with with again the
aspiring alpaca like I'm really really
trying to build this and so I just broke
a v friend this is very upsetting guys
live in the mirror me trying to be cool
so there's no nft element to these
things they're just the Visa
intuitive iguana oh my God what happened
I did bad nothing no no surprise inside
of there what's it smell like
okay so with with these products there's
no nft aspect or like web3 aspect
they're just a physical product of a
metaverse nft my job is to bring value
yeah now if you own these characters in
nft form you're getting this stuff for
free but my but I'm doing two things at
once one
access if you own The Wine Cellar
background in series two you came to the
store you got free wine you got it for
your q a experience right
and then building Affinity this
collaboration this execution is about
getting many many many more people in
the world to care about these characters
which manifests in many different ways
ultimately for me the catch-all is the
people owning the nfts especially series
one
like I I stay up at night thinking about
this
I've got 40 years 50 years you know I'm
46 40 50 60 years
and I've got to do as much demand
creation much Affinity storytelling
and I've got to do a lot of technology
and utility and and I've got to bring
value what's what's what's a typical V
friend holder like I mean you've you
must have met you've probably gamut you
know as you guys know I brought so many
new people into the space because I had
a big audience and they run the gamut
like true investors collectors flippers
just people that have appreciated my
content that just want to own one for
collectible the same reason I collect
Jets I mean why do I have this Carmelo
Anthony he brought me happiness Carmelo
brought me happy you know the Knicks
didn't you know he I like him so I buy
that like a lot of people like that I
taught them common sense and so they're
gonna buy this you know there's like
there's a lot of different reasons but
um you know and then just other people
in the space that you know I think
there's a lot of people that are
starting to realize during this you know
not as hot Market that it will come down
to the operator like everyone's like the
community the community well what
happens when the community loses 90 of
its value the community turns on the
project
and I think you know it's up to the
operator to re-change that momentum and
so
I've been I've been quiet you know I've
been quiet because I've been focused
just very very focused on what I have to
do here in the uh in the chat we got
Brian Lowe and also me uh asking this
question what would you say what do you
have to say for a 20 year old like me
who wants to start his own nft project
or perhaps somebody like bankless or uh
somebody who is in content or Media or
just like adjacent and
48 it's like making an app everybody
wanted to make an app when apps exploded
everybody asked me Gary what app should
I make I said one that brings people
value nothing changes what should
Bankers do like I don't know like you
guys have a real [ __ ] show I have a
funny feeling that people would like to
come and see it live create an nft that
gives the you know access to the 12 live
appearances in 2023 where there's a
party and I think I can get Ryan Sean
Adams to leave his house 12 times in
2023 at your house
so you know I think I think yes to the
20 year old I also would say to the 20
year old you know I worked in my dad's
liquor store for 14 years
building it for my dad and but I earned
my stripes and learned operations and so
you know one thing that a 20 year old
should consider is special right now
where a lot of people are not hiring as
much they can probably use good young
aggressive Talent maybe go get a job at
one of the top 100 projects and get paid
to learn
like I don't understand people people
are willing to go into massive depth for
college to learn something fake but like
that normative companies when they don't
pay him as much as they ideologically
think yet they're learning a ton
I'd much rather if I'm a 20 year old
Curious in the space get paid minimum
wage to work for Doodles than to go into
debt at Wisconsin I totally agree I mean
[ __ ] the time to do it is now too it's
the bear Market it's not during the book
a hundred it's always the bear Market
that's awesome I'm so pumped pumped
right now
like I'm loving this like
it's like nobody's like I'm just trying
to like work
build and make good decisions I mean I
made a decision for gift goat this
morning that won't manifest until August
of next year
and it's a good one that I really need
for that micro Community but like
they're not gonna you know I'm not gonna
get the benefit of that until August
but that's what it requires and so you
have to have the stomach to deal with
like people being patient so I'm excited
like you you mentioned um you mentioned
like technology a couple of times and
I'm curious from your state as an
operator as a builder in the nft space
like what still needs to be built out
like what's hard like I mean we're
trying to do things things that
eliminate friction right for example
we're gonna have a massive upgrade to
our website like we're going password
and email for the people that want to do
it because and that's a web 2 function
but that was like you can't do that 18
months ago it had to be all web three so
I think what I call Web 2.5 a lot more
web 2.5
strategies I think matter but there's a
there's a lot of
things that quote unquote need to be
built uh warm wallets right like you
know like are starting to room like
there's just a lot of cool stuff like
unlimited stuff like uh nft readers
QR readers are nice now right credit
card with chip readers are nice right
now both those didn't exist 10 years ago
in America
you're up on the QR on the uh chip right
like that stuff's way better
and so like we need more of that right
we need we need like could you imagine
you have an nft there's a replicant made
that can sit in a hot wallet that
doesn't allow somebody to steal your
actual nft that's validated that you go
to Madison Square Garden right there I'm
looking at it and if you own the common
sense cow you can see the cows the
hottest band in the world perform a
making up that the cows are now a hot
band you know but like you know there's
so much so much and wait to Apple and
Facebook and Google like I mean I don't
know did you see this Gary so um it's
been a beta previously but um last week
it looked like meta just rolled out um
nft validation for uh Instagram so now
you can like and like that's huge man I
mean Instagram this was 1.5 billion
something absolutely massive in terms of
its reach and they are now supporting
nfts and this is happening during the
bear Market they're all gonna do it
they're all gonna do it
it's it's look the conversation isn't
about the underlying Tech or the smart
strategic operations it's about
speculation of pricing it's almost like
everyone's paying attention to the value
of the comic books not the ability to
print you know paper when if like if
paper one wasn't invented yet like like
you know the analogy is like everyone's
worried about you know
the the it's why Wall Street [ __ ] me up
like everybody worrying about the stock
Pro all my clients of vaynermedia have
worse businesses than they could because
they all care about their stock price
every 90 days instead of building a real
business
and so I think that's my hope that more
operators focus on not so many you see
this you guys are paying attention so
many projects are doing such short-term
things to appease
a small percentage of people in their
Discord who are fighting who aren't who
don't necessarily uh aren't necessarily
doing the wrong thing they're worried
about their self-interest they should
they're human beings but that's a bad
job by the operator can you imagine
every head coach in sports listening to
the crowd and making his or her
decisions on the next play based on that
foreign
steering uh it's a tail wagon the dog
100 and uh it's only the operator that's
gonna have the vision for the long term
how do you like corral your community or
just like get them to see the same
vision that you do or are there is there
a trick to this or or is it just like
straight up being like raw and authentic
yeah and just like limiting I think I
was too involved in the community early
on meaning like I was like part of it I
almost forgot it was mine I was like
you know I think for example Jaya we're
just said hand waved away the only
semi-technical softball question G is
here to pump a bag Jay Edward said like
I'm I'm really not I'm like like I
because it's not gonna work I don't
think people understand
like there is no pumping
like there is no pumping in this market
this is why I've been so utterly quiet I
just [ __ ] with you guys and like
I had to go somewhere to talk about the
toy drop right and I and I needed
somewhere to like allocate some time and
talk about what I've been up to because
I've been quieter but like my preference
is to stay unbelievably quiet and I'll
tell you why
what's cool about when you're quiet is
the real ones who really believe
actually support and then you're pumped
when you know you're [ __ ] got it I
know I got it but to be like
you think it's gonna matter what the
[ __ ] anybody says anywhere it's not
gonna matter
just like when I [ __ ] sit this
weekend
at MetLife Stadium and eat my [ __ ]
popcorn and talk [ __ ] about Teddy
Bridgewater it's not gonna stop Teddy
Bridgewater from playing a good football
game
and so for me for me I don't I'm
actually looking to get super duper
quiet because there's an incredible
feeling of knowing what I'm actually
doing and then letting the people that
held all the way through or the people
that are coming in when it's least
obvious like you're happy for that the
thing that only part that hurts me right
now is watching people sell when they
don't when they when for no reason you
know it's one reason somebody sold
recently and I emailed him and said I'm
happy you sold I think you need I get
that you need it
I was happy but people that are selling
out of just like some Randomness
thinking that's going to mean anything
like trying to well a lot of people I'm
selling it because things drop that's
why they sell somebody emailed me and
said Gary I'm emailing you I'm selling
these three to make a point and I
replied and I was like to make a point
about what he's like well you need to be
I'm like I am
and then I reminded that gentleman I got
on the call with him and reminded him
that I've been building businesses for
25 years
what you what you want the person
operating to do is different than
what an operator may want to do when you
say I am is that is that instant
messenger
okay
a DM DM DM DM okay right okay they just
wanted you to be interacting with them
in in the community do you do you have a
community manager who like fills the
void in your absence or is it actually
oh yeah we have tons of mods like but
like but like I want to do a lot of the
speaking but like Andy the president may
there's plenty of them doing some
speaking here in their course so many
others Daniel Tyler
um but I like doing the speaking but but
I'm not so sold like that you know you
got to find the right balance of
speaking you know like you you want to
speak when there's something to speak
about right you know to me speaking
about the Toys R Us Macy's collaboration
makes sense like it's a significant
distribution deal this is not a direct
to Consumer thing that we've seen from
every other project
where you have to send your audience to
your.com this is uh
hundreds of thousands of people in the
next hundred days during the holiday
season are going to stumble on this
these characters click the QR codes fall
in love Google buy nnft like this is
real hmm yeah I um you know I think the
only thing that can be done at some
point with all of the Skeptics and all
the people who throw flood and shade is
just like out build them right and show
them on the other side and sometimes
that won't even shut them up but um yeah
but I love but I like that
I like the fud yeah does it fuel you
does it make you like more excited to
build or does it like because I know
some people who just they see that
negativity and they it discourages them
no no no that's someone who's gotta
rethink why they're like what they're
doing why should that discourage you
these people are entitled to their
opinion it's it's wonderful like freedom
of thought you know
Gary who else is in the crypto World nft
World creator world doing cool stuff
that you like all right what other
projects are out there that Captivate
capture your attention
um
you know I'm not sure like I'll give you
an example I know more what my mod
Crystal does and her incredible talent
in my world
then I know what my homie Kevin Rose is
doing with moon Birds right now or or
like me cheering heavy for World of
women women of weapons Doodles like
there's there's so many people that I
hope are crushing I'm not in the phase
right now where I have a great read of
what
you know
you know
the projects are doing like you know I'm
aware of that poobs nfts ninth on on on
on open C right now because I can look I
can look at ABC right now I can look at
all this stuff I see it I just you know
I just don't have the time right now I'm
not in collector mode like I was a year
ago so I wanted to know everything about
every project I'm in building V friends
mode for real for real
and
um
and that's where I'm at
Gary this has been a lot of fun man
thanks for updating us on so many things
last last question for you just to kind
of round out we've been talking to nfts
we've been talking nft we've been
talking V friends but um zoom out to
kind of you know crypto for for a minute
if you will
um what's your temperature on like
crypto assets these days you know like
the Bitcoins the ethers of the world
yeah
if you can look back to 18 months ago
I've never really spoken about
currencies I don't have a good read you
don't even have a read yeah I really
don't I I own those two I own Solana I
don't know what else I own
and it's not where I feel comfortable
because I understand branding and human
behavior and what the creators of a
project can do for utility with
currencies themselves there's a lot of
need for it to do something and I'm sure
those things will come it's just not my
passion place I'm never gonna Financial
engineer it's not what I'm good at
I think the D5 stuff is super
fascinating but it's a little too math
for me I love the art and the human
meaning I love the math of it I think
it's very fast you're a community
builder at your core yeah I'm a
Storyteller I like marketing I like I
know why Nike is worth a trillion I know
why that swoosh matters I know what I'm
doing and what I'm doing and so I try to
stay where I'm
comfortable and that's a much more
comfortable in nft land than I am in
cryptocurrency land that's cool well
thanks for stopping by and uh so refresh
us again when can people see the friends
at their local Macy's
uh mid-october October 17th I think is
when they really start supposedly hit
the shelves I'm a retailer so I know
some people keep in the back until the
next week but you know every Macy's that
has a Toys R Us inside of it at
macys.com right now and and please
garyvee.com Discord come and hang like
that's where all the alpha all the links
you don't have the guests around or
Google quick question from YouTube will
the toys be available in the UK yes we
friends shop is gonna launch on the 17th
the day they physically hit stores with
pre-sale and actually purchased for
international so we're going full
International as well
[Music]